[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was people assume I'm
voting for Obama because I'm Donald
Glover wrote young and black Neil
Patrick Harris wrote gay and liberal
Steven Tyler wrote old and female this
country would be better off if Rush
Limbaugh wrote Romney wins a vowel and
Gauri I wrote Obama wins
Bill Clinton wrote your dinner at
Hooters showed up on your credit card
statement as unicef contribution would
be a better country my favorite place to
hang out by myself is Julie Bowen wrote
a big chair by the fireplace Antonio
Banderas wrote the ocean at sunset kanye
west wrote the Hall of Mirrors on Kanye
Mao
thanks to Fame I Tom Hanks wrote can't
walk down the street Meryl Streep wrote
have to go out in disguise honey Boo
Boo's mom wrote never have to wait for a
table at Long John Silver if Mitt Romney
wins the presidential election I will
Chuck Norris wrote celebrate Alec
Baldwin wrote leave the country and
Romney wrote have to move into that
dreary little shack over on Pennsylvania
Avenue when I hear that a celebrity has
died I
Chelsea Handler wrote think of their
friends and family Joanie Hill wrote
think about all their accomplishments
Wilford Brimley wrote assumed that it's
me
[Applause]
okay then it's got to be a relief though
when he figures it out on election night
on election night it's so exciting to
see Jason Segel wrote who wins and who
loses ellie kemper wrote which
propositions pass and which don't
kim jeong-hoon wrote who voted for me
and who will be killed
yay the system works ma'am soul-crushing
dictatorship if I could change one thing
about myself it would be Bob Saget wrote
my speaking voice I'd like it to be
deeper
Matt Damon wrote my eyes they're too
widely set Gary Busey wrote my pants
I've wanted to change them for weeks but
I don't want them together I'm sick of
being judged for my Tom Hanks wrote
early movie roles Jennifer Aniston wrote
romantic decisions Oh Jay Simpson wrote
murders
[Applause]
he's like move on all that time is
passed when I saw the pictures of all
the hurricane flooding i lisa kudrow
wrote prayed for all involved
Vince Vaughn wrote had flashbacks to
Katrina our Kelly wrote got an erection
damn it why can't I be
oh poor guy poor guy I know what he's
going through and finally my dad was the
first man to Barry Bonds wrote hit 300
homers and steal 400 bases Lisa Marie
Presley wrote have 15 number one hits
Larry King wrote walk upright
[Applause]